ترسخوا ايران نفسها عبر مؤسساتها وعبر
اذرعها ايضا وليس سياسيا وامنيا فحسب انما
اقتصاديا على الوجه الاخر للنفوذ
الايرانيه المتمدده في العراق وعنوانه
ميليشيا الحشد الشعبي
اترى قرار الحكومه العراقيه بالموافقه على
انشاء شركه عامه براس مالا يقارب السبعين
مليون دولار الكثير من القلق في البلاد
لماذا
الارتباط هذه الشركه بالحشد الشعبي والتي
سميت بشركه المهندس بالنسبه لابي المهدي
المهندس بقى رئيس الحشد الذي اختلته
واشنطن مع قاسم سليمان قائد فيلق القدس في
يناير 2020 لكن اين يكمن القلق مهمه
الشركات تتمثلوا في اعاده تاهيل البنيه
التحتيه في المحافظات وهو ما قاضي يعني ان
الحشد تحول الى مؤسسه ربحيه بيدران
ليس هذا فحسب الخطوه وصفت بحشدنه الاقتصاد
العراقي وتوغل المليشيا في صناعات الدوله
ومواردها وهو ما سيعني ان ثنائيه المال
والسلاح ستقتل اي منافسه على فرص
الاستثمار الامر اشبه باستنساخ تجربه
الحرس الثوري والبسيج اجنحه النظام
الايراني المهيمنه على الاقتصاد في ايران
الذي انه اصلا والاقتصاد العراقي الذي
يعاني بلاساس ستزيد معاناته يبقى سؤال هنا
هنا اين الولايات المتحده من كل هذا في
الخفاء تعرف واشنطن ان الاطراف التي شكلت
الحكومه معروفه بعدائها لها بحكم ولائها
لايران لكن في العالم تؤكد امريكا دائما
انها لن تترك العراق زي العراق الست في
غضون شهر قامت بها السفيره الامريكيه في
بغداد لرئيس الوزراء محمد شياع السوداني
امرهن يحدث للمره الاولى مع رئيس حكومه
لكن
هذا كافل لمواجهه الهيمنه الايرانيه عمليا
لا واشنطن لديها اولويات حرب اوكرانيا
وروسيا ومواجهه نفوذ الصين
تحاول ايران الالتفاف على العقوبات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه الاقتصاديه المفروضه
عليها من خلال السوق العراقي والتي تسعى
للسيطره على اغلب المفاصلها والتي تعتبر
الاقرب لها جغرافيا وحتى سياسيه
الحديقه الخلفيه او الرئه الاقتصاديه
لايران هكذا ترى طهران العراق والسبب
الميزان التجاري الذي يبلغوا نحو عشره
مليارات دولار سنويا من خلال اغلاق السوق
العراقيه بالبضائع والسلع الايرانيه حيث
يعتبر العراق النافذه الاكبر في المنطقه
للصادرات الايرانيه تسيطر ايران بشكل شبه
كامل على سوق الطاقه في العراق من خلال
تجهيز نحوي نصفي ما يحتاجه العراق من
الكهرباء والغاز لسد احتياجاته لمنظمته
الكهربائيه اضافه لعمل الشركات النفطيه
الايرانيه في جنوبيه العراق قطاع
المصاريفي وشركات الصرافه هي الاخرى لم
تسلم من اذرع طيران التي تعمل على توفير
الدولار لايران والذي وصل الى ارقام
قياسيه مقابل التومان الايراني من خلال
بيع العمله ومؤسسه الماليه العراق